in the scenic beauty of a remote Rocky
Mountain Town military political
business and Tech leaders gathered for
the Aspen security Forum where the
safety of artificial intelligence is a
major issue I think we have to stay
anchored on this question of safe and
effective and I think we should be clear
that we actually don't have tools and
methods today to know when something
when an AI model is safe and effective
so that definition would have been not
safe and effective we simply don't know
technology experts warn that AI tools
already available can be enormously
destructive right now for example any
individual who spends enough time with
these tools or even without knowing
computer science
can use these tools to generate fakes of
Warren Buffett saying something that he
never said causing a crash on the market
or having President Biden say something
that he never said causing International
turmoil AI is changing the face of War
when I talked to the U.S defense
department for example
um they're quite worried they're worried
about lethal autonomous weapons also
vulnerable to malicious actors using AI
critical infrastructure like the
electrical grid an intelligent adversary
can use these tools to really hone in on
the particularly weak link that could
then cause a Cascade failure or or what
we call a Black Swan event
and for some kinds of malicious AI it
may already be too late the techniques
used to generate deep fake audio video
Etc they're out there the cats out of
the bag the message seems to be getting
through experts and government officials
here are talking about ways to regulate
AI but meanwhile the technology is
becoming more advanced by the minute Rob
Reynolds Al Jazeera Aspen Colorado